je
des chances et quelques très juste
un adjectif ça serait investie
réactif
c'est richard le gâteau
je m'appelle la dodge du chat donc je
suis en bonne santé
j'ai trois enfants une femme que j'aime
le plus au monde et surtout ma mère
mon père est décédé aujourd'hui je suis
responsable technique au théâtre de
champ fleuri
libéré de charasse qui va nous sourire
ça c'est mon placard où les
attendaient à manger la messe dans la
table
voilà ça suffit pas
lyall matin les oiseaux et on tue
les puces des moustiques
tout le monde est bienvenu tout le monde
est bienvenu way to bienvenus
d'abord des herbes après maïs ils vont
faire un peu la gueule
assez peu dans la marmite
je veux dire à un moment donné c'est la
vie c'est les animaux ça fait partie de
bain et puis c'est vivant c'est pas
quelque chose de statique moi j'aime
bien tout ce qui est vivant quoi je
préfère plus avoir des rapports avec des
gens que du du matériel
après ma femme est réveillé
et très actif
partout il faut qu il bouge il peut pas
s'asseoir un moment dit ah bon
restez là sont les affaires il faut qu
il bouge tout le temps la gt ou à les
battre
et aux
dents longues à son
vin je vais très court je vis ça depuis
le ventre de ma mère c'est le fruit
d'une conjugaison je dirais oui et je
dirais même plus en fait c'est j'ai
toujours rêvé de faire ce métier être
proches de l'artiste et être aussi
artiste d'un côté et bricoleur
bidouilleurs donc du coup ça tombe très
bien le technicien c'est quelqu'un qui
est prêt d'un artiste qui peut être
technicien aussi et qui est bricoleur
mais si pau situé de ma journée
française décale et je mets au set avant
le satyre qu'aujourd'hui et en même
temps je regarde qui travaillent
aujourd'hui
c'est bon donc à 13 heures 13 heures 13
heures et je dois avoir un intermittent
ce matin pour mettre en place combien de
temps au théâtre en fait j'étais
embauché en 92 en cdi mais
j'ai participé à on va dire
l'inauguration pas officiel il ya 30 ans
et
j'ai travaillé aussi au crack qui était
la structure qui gérait le théâtre en
tant que vacataire intermittents
bénévoles artis
je prépare aussi papier que je mets dans
la poche et je note toutes les priorités
du jour
et si un souci que je dois faire un
rapport je vais me tuer mon petit papier
à la poche les écrirait ses paroles sans
voler comme un oiseau là parce que de
temps en temps je vais mais un petit peu
mis de pain qu'elle de trois qui vont
venir dans l'instant
allez on va faire petit one et
c'est un peu comme autres classes de
vrais jeux contrôle toujours joué à
l'époque les trucs que j'ai un coup
d'oeil décider s'il était à faire bonne
santé
un collègue
voilà ce qu'on savait informatique ibm
toi bien
la ola frédéric sept secrétaires sympa
nathalie secrétaire sympa et nadine
lacomme aux secrétaires sympa c'est le
bon joueur qui est important le bonjour
même s'il ya des conflits même s'il ya
des des malentendus même s'il ya des
décors elle même si elle est mauvaise
santé tout ça pour moi le bon jour est
important
parce que le bonjour c'est le respect de
l'autre pour moi c'est je respecte
toujours toujours les autres personnes
parce que le respect de lot on sera
respectée après j'ai beaucoup appris ça
en afrique beaucoup appris ça qu'au
début on a nous la programmation et qui
doit être réalisée par la concrétisation
sur la scène et richard il a en charge
toute cette partie là donc tous les
imprévus arrive toujours au dernier
moment parce que quand il s'agit de
travailler sur le papier tout va bien
mais quand on rentre vraiment dans la
réalité la réalisation des spectacles
cela c'est là pour voir qui manque ou de
la lumière ou du sourd et nous surprend
winnie nous surprend parce qu'il va
toujours trouver la solution qu'il faut
pour arriver à la fin
alors là
on va lever le rideau de fer
pour préparer le nettoyage rideaux pare
flammes
alors ça c'est du gazon et je vous pose
une question à ce que c'est du vrai ou
du faut trouver des solutions à tous les
délires oui c'est un peu mon métier et
pour moi il ya deux mots je vais dire
impossible c'est pas français
et il est interdit d'interdire
parce que je pense que si l'artiste est
à l'aise sur scène le spectacle qui sera
bon le public sera content et la
technique sera contente
bon c'est sûr a pris au niveau du
nettoyage on a une super équipe ici au
théâtre de champ fleuri on a trois
techniciens de surface qui font un
boulot extra et il ya une très ancienne
dans cette maison qui a connu des
artistes depuis plus de 20 ans n'est ce
pas luciane le jeudi 20 ans je suis
gentil il faut que ce soit arrivé parce
qu'il connaît bien ici son travail à
aulas il faut que richard soit là la
maison une bonne ambiance et tout il
faut ça qu'on travaille dans le théâtre
il faut avoir le sourire tout parce
qu'il faut à recueillir les indices à
aubry sinon les artistes vont pas venir
qui a pâti susi
donc oui
il faut le mettre de côté c'est là qu'on
avance dans la vie
regardez les 46 l'artiste va arriver là
teaser est à 10 heures six ans aient
commencé il ya plus de monde à l'humour
je veux leur dire d'un michel bassi
l'allée rouge
donc on fait comment chaque artiste a un
caractère différent donc c'est pour ça
comme je te disais il faut l'écouter
comprendre comment il est savoir ce
qu'il veut c'est sa plus dure parce que
souvent les gens ne savent pas ce qu'ils
veulent il vient de théâtre de champ
fleuri ils ont signé leur contrat ils
sont 10 ha oui je suis au théâtre
champfleury faut tout revoir je dis non
inventeur
je vais moindre trapèze
on l'a gagnée sur trapèze
personne ne voit que c'est une table
vélo c'est vrai c'est ça le secret de la
technique un tycoon honnêteté
voilà
et maintenant je vais dire que ces prix
et c'est à eux de jouer il ya 30 ans ou
même pose cette évolution on fait
beaucoup plus de spectra niffer station
et je pense qu'on a moins le temps de
jouir d'une manifestation c'est à dire
que on devient un peu plus à faire du
garage charente ça sent ça rentre ça
sort on jouit pas vraiment des bons
moments je parle des créations on a pu
les mêmes moyens aussi mais je pense que
on arrive à trouver bon moi je m'amuse
je vous dis franchement sur les galas
d'école c'est génial parce qu'on a des
gens qui sont motivés on a des gens qui
se donnent à fond
bonjour la communication n'est c'est ma
relation publique jeune public
zhuhai a coiffé la communication ce sont
des personnes et surtout riche à quand
des personnes qui ont la conscience de
de l'outil qu'est le théâtre champfleury
puisqu'il est le régisseur ici est aussi
une fête ils accueillent du public il
accueille aussi des artistes des
artistes qui viennent d'ici mais qui
vient aussi de l'extérieur un théâtre on
a quand même de la chance il faut le
dire c'est beaucoup de travail c'est
beaucoup d'investissement mais voilà
c'est ce que croit que si on est heureux
c'est parce qu'on a envie de partager ce
plaisir de la culture et c'est bien
qu'ils aient des tempéraments comme
celui de richard
au théâtre parce qu'effectivement il
garde cette fraîcheur et cette volonté
de montrer de belles choses évidemment
les choses évoluent richard on se
connaît depuis qu'on est tout petit on
habite la réunion moi j'ai pensé que sa
maman quand j'étais petit la mandale
sous serment du plateau la vallée de
l'ance donc voilà donc c'est des choses
qui qui qui lie cette silence
j'avais jaune pour étudiants ben
j'arrête un moment j'ai fatigue et non
il faudra toujours ça ce que je souhaite
qu'il reste avec 7,7 cet investissement
qui peut avoir pour la culture que ce
soit dans ses théâtres ou ailleurs
chaque personne s'il a trouvé
l'épanouissement qu'il faut dans son
travail et bah il
il s'éclate ce qui compte pour moi c'est
d'être en bonne santé lors s c'est des
conneries voilà mon avenir